let's sort of do like a pretty harsh
segue into this other segment that's uh
about critical race theory and social
justice stuff but it's more about uh
men and women and and child ring and
stuff i i
normally like to make sure we keep
everything in a standard through line
but this one's too interesting to pass
up because matthew iglesias
so matthew iglesias is the co-founder of
vox.com and he tweeted this today
here's a poll that could burn the
discourse down
and i don't know why he posted it but
it's family work preference
based on gender and marital parental
status and the funny thing is i don't
think there's anything necessarily
definitive from it
but we do see that married mothers
overwhelmingly believe around 55 percent
that one parent should work full time
and one parent should provide child care
in the home
and married fathers basically think the
same thing but you know what's really
funny about this
married mothers only about 15 percent
think both parents should work full time
and use child care work married fathers
you actually have around 25 who think
both parents should be working full-time
and using paid childcare i think it's
funny that more guys think that and i
think it's because men
probably underestimate the amount of
work that goes into raising kids
so they're like ah my wife can work it's
no big deal we'll get a child you know a
sitter and the wife is like no no no
you you underestimate but interestingly
there's a poll from 2019 that matthew
also uh posted
56 percent of women prefer working to
homemaking i think there's interesting
ramifications from this notably that
the number is actually 56 for women and
uh who prefer to work outside the home
but 75 percent for men
and then 39 of women prefer being a
homemaker and only 23
of men my question and what i want to
just i want to get into like just kind
of the gender dynamics especially with
you here mike
about what you think this leads to why
it's happening and yeah
we were talking about testosterone
before and like men's testosterone
levels going down so i figured it'd be
fun to talk about this
yeah those things i'm surprised the
numbers aren't inverse where
more people want to be stay-at-home moms
one thing i've i've got with
uh sean is shauna would be a little bit
insecure to say that she was a
stay-at-home mom
because she would get like shamed by
other women for being a stay-at-home mom
but if why would you shame someone if
you were happy
right that that's where i think the
numbers are probably even
even more skewed towards they actually
don't want to work because
they think about if you're happy and
somebody says oh yeah i'm doing this
thing like me oh yeah i like to lift
weights and you tell me i like to bike
you tell me you like to run you like to
run you like to bike and i'm like
i'm glad that everybody's really happy
so she would feel like put on the spot
right because there's all this like
shame directed by women who are like
only
a stay-at-home mom i couldn't do it i
could just
i know i believe in mindset your limits
blah blah blah
i could not be all the time with the
kids the way my wife
this is this is like the the one subject
that when i when we talk about
triggers the most anger from leftists
and i don't
i mean i can probably make some
assumptions as to why they get so mad
about it because maybe it's what you
kind of pointed out that there's a lot
of women who would rather
be homemakers i mean the gallup poll
says that maybe there are more but
they're worried about being
shunned or shamed well parenting does
too so shauna
it's so interesting because i you know i
see things from her perspective too is
anything about parenting makes people
mad so for example i did a whole thread
on how we did natural childbirth and i
prefaced it with hey man if you went to
the hospital
i just hope your kids are healthy all
love blessings
love and light how dare you you're
giving misinformation about home births
and
they're yelling so anytime you do
something about parenting
you're already in the danger zone
because people take it personally
oh so you read to your kids three books
a day i only read one book a day to my
kid
you're there for saying that i'm a bad
parent like nobody nobody's telling you
that bro
we're just like hanging out so you're
already in the danger zone and then when
you talk about anything with
the idea that there's like a traditional
gender roles might actually have a
biological root to it
now you're you've doubled it right
whatever whatever your because
if all you talked about was peaceful
parenting you would have people mad at
you well i was
thanked as a kid and i turned out you
know good so you're already there and
i'm not even saying biological component
i'm just like oh look at this poll that
says men prefer it more than
i'm sorry women prefer it more than men
and then
man people just light up well that's
something they're going to read that
into it though
oh they're going to go of course oh so
because they all rate you know they're
raised on like jon stewart and john oh
so what you're saying
is that men belong and the working and
women belong in the house like bro i
never
said that i mean i'm just talking about
an actual survey so i can just say that
i
could not i could not be a mom
and i i don't have to pander to women
because money says men
all blessings to them there's an article
i read that really triggered the left
and it like seriously did they started
writing articles about it and yelling at
me and i got a bunch of people hitting
me up
because it was about working women in
their 30s who couldn't find
men and i'm like maybe there is
something with this gallup poll and this
other discourse
that matthew glacier has tweeted where
if you got a guy who's in his 30s
who's successful and attractive he's not
going to want to find a woman who
you know wants to work he wants to find
someone who can help him have a family
yeah
there's a lot of things you can
misinterpret with opinions but one thing
you can't misinterpret are the financial
ramifications that cause people
to have a home where both of the parents
work it used to be that someone would
have one job and they could pay for
their family they could pay for their
mortgage
they could pay for the food on the table
now that situation is dramatically going
down especially with energy prices going
up housing prices going up
food prices going up this is affecting
us in such dramatic ways and we have to
understand behind
the larger movement especially in the
early onset of the 1900s
there was a lot of industrialists that
saw
that if we have more taxpayers if we
have more workers if we have more
factory people
if we have more employees to choose from
wages will naturally go down and that's
why big time industrialists like
rockefeller were big time proponents
of uh movements that made women go into
the workforce so
there are natural incentives sure i
don't even want to go there the
financial incentives are something that
we should be having a bigger
conversation on
because these are the talking points
that do affect us and we need to realize
that in america
a single working family home cannot
make ends meet one person working can't
happen what's going to happen
two people are going to have to work and
they're going to have to rely on illegal
labor to raise their children
why well there's a bunch of different
jobs in this country there's average
very few that could survive and sustain
a family
what's on average on the medium i'll
just tell you man i've been
blessed in life um it's hard out there
man i when i go because i don't do a lot
of the shopping
um at the at the albertsons or whatever
you should go to costco buying bulk
i went to buy halloween candy and i was
like how how is peanut m
ms you know 44 or whatever for
it goes faster when you have kids it
goes faster like diapers and everything
it it's hard man let's look so there
there are some personalities
who uh had kids when they were extremely
young
and became extremely successful i think
that one of the issues you've got a
bunch of young men
who are sitting around doing nothing
that's why jor one of the reasons i
think jordan peterson became so popular
is that he was trying to give young men
purpose
and i think it's one of the reasons why
the far left got really mad about it but
if you got a bunch of guys who are
working maybe you know let's say they're
working 40 hours a week
are they really striving and are they
providing that level of
of demand to a boss let me clarify let's
say you're
23 and you're working at a
best buy or something you're you're not
gonna you're not gonna go to your boss
and you know put pressure on them and
try and find more work because you're
probably making more than enough you go
home you play world of warcraft you play
destiny whatever video games you're into
minecraft or whatever film some youtube
videos maybe and then you're done let's
say you're 23 and you got a
three-year-old kid
you're gonna go to your boss and be like
i need more money and he's gonna be like
we can't give you more money say okay
then you're gonna start looking in the
classifieds
then you're gonna be like i have no
choice i have to find something bigger
and better
i i you you literally have no choice i
think that people are missing
responsible in their lives that's that
would normally
drive them to to succeed and do better
i'm not saying it's absolute i'm not
saying everybody i'm not even taking a
majority i'm just saying i think that is
a component for a lot of people
because i know it is hard out there i
know a lot of people struggle to make
ends meet
but i also know there are a lot of
people so i i knew i knew people back
where i grew up on the south side
of chicago who found a way to go from
being a high school dropout to making
six figures
because they literally had no choice
they had a kid when they were a teenager
and they started working 80 hours a week
and then every opportunity they saw they
took they pressured their bosses and
they said
i got a kid i got to make more money and
then by the time they were 20 they were
a manager making six figures at some
company
there's that i mean there's so you
raised a lot of there's so much swirl
which is the idea that a lot of reason
reasons that young men aren't driven is
because the dating is a disaster
unless you're like a very top-tier guy i
read some statistic on how many people
ever get matched on these dating apps
so the the way the dating system has
it's actually kind of wild if you think
about
if you're like a top tier guy you can
have four f
they're called they call them spin and
plays you can have four or five
different girls that you're dating
and they just kind of accept it like
that's the way it is and you have all
the leverage
and then if you're just like a guy who's
maybe above average a little bit above
average
you're good luck dude thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have
full bonus episodes thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time
you